thank you for being with us apologies
for the delay in getting to you this
morning and the government's published
its battle plan for dealing with
coronavirus so what's your what are you
gonna do well we've got a clear strategy
for dealing with coronavirus a very very
significant challenge as we were
discussing there with John McDonald and
the the the plan is very clear firstly
to contain this virus that's the stage
we're in now we hope that we can succeed
in doing that it means that every single
case that is found here gets immediate
not only treatment but also we contact
all of the people that that person has
been in close contact with we make sure
they get the full medical advice and we
try to stop the spread that here in the
UK of course those cases coming in
largely most of the cases so far are
from people who've caught the virus
elsewhere and brought it here and we're
then able to contain it but of course
well Sui whilst we're doing that we're
also planning in case this guess worse
much worse and that has three strands to
it the first is to delay the onset
because it's far better if if we do get
this in a big way it's far better if
that happens in the summer and it's also
better if the if the peak is not as as
high so to speak if the timing of it is
spread out the third strand is to
research would put 40 million pounds
into trying to find a vaccine and also
trying to improve the treatments for
people who do have the disease and we
can talk about that but the the the
experts say that a vaccine even as
accelerated as fast as possible is still
many months off but the potential for
treatments that make the make the virus
less of a problem if you've got it they
are more optimistic and then the final
part of the plan is to prepare for
mitigation should this become endemic in
this country as it has in other parts of
the world and making sure that the
not only the NHS is prepared of course
but also all parts of society and this
is something where government has got a
huge role to play but so does every
single person actually I want to talk
about washing I want to talk a bit more
about that as well because many of our
viewers we're thinking what steps should
I be taking to protect myself to protect
my family the director-general of the
World Health Organization for example
tweeting that over-60 should avoid
crowded areas places where they could
interact with people who are sick I mean
is that good advice should people over
60 be avoiding public transport not
going to routine appointments with their
GP well not now because the number of
cases is is still relatively low and as
I say we're trying to contain each and
every one if we get to the position
where this is endemic right around the
world and an large scale here then we
will change the advice and according to
what the scientists advise for the what
is the best sort of behavior so at the
moment the best thing people can do is
make sure that they wash their hands for
20 seconds or more
we're telling children that you've got
to wash your hands whilst you sing happy
birthday to make sure that gets through
very simply making sure that you use
soap and hot water that is the single
best thing that everybody can do and
also catch a cough or a sneeze if you if
if that happens and then thirdly follow
the public health advice if you think
you've got it now it'll if we get to a
position where this is much more
widespread then of course we're we we
will change the advice to deal with that
but at this stage people should go about
their ordinary business you know I want
to minimise the risk to the public but
we also want to minimize the social and
economic disruption that will be
inevitably caused and we've already seen
it this week caused by a virus like this
at the same time they some will be
thinking the government sounds like it's
just waiting until things get worse and
aren't the things that people should be
doing now
to prevent that situation happening in
France for example they banned indoor
gatherings of more than 5,000 people is
this the kind of thing that the UK
government should be considering
well we're considering all options we
have a we have a full range of planning
I've been undertaking cobras for several
weeks now and and leading that planning
with the prime minister and making sure
that we've got all those plans in place
but there's a there's there's a there's
a danger to doing things too early
because they wouldn't be effective at
the moment the number of cases in this
country is 23 and that means that so
long as people are washing their hands
and taking the precautions that are set
out that is the right thing to do we
don't rule out taking any of these other
measures and there are there are more
cases in France Germany Italy than there
are here in the UK but we but we will
advise on those measures when it is
right to take them because as I say we
want to minimize the economic and social
disruption subject to keeping people
safe and is this a balancing act then
between keeping people safe and
minimizing the economic disruption look
it's a balancing act where I place the
greatest weight on keeping people safe
but there's no point in doing things
that aren't clinically effective we have
to be guided by the science here I think
that's a really important principle so
when people come to me with suggestions
of things that we should do in order to
minimize it I'm I will check those with
the epidemiologists with the scientists
who are some of the best scientists in
the world and if they're effective then
we'll consider doing them but if they're
not going to be effective then then
that's why we choose not to for instance
you know in the last couple of weeks
I've had some people say to me why don't
we just stop all flights from China and
I asked the the the chief medical
officer and he explained that if you do
that then people find other ways to come
into this country we're a very open
country and indeed the only European
country that did do that and stop
all the flights that was Italy and
they've ended up as the having more
cases than any other European country
because it wasn't an effective thing to
do and so that's the approach that we're
taking we are looking at every single
option and we're planning with a clear
battle plan for how we how we rise to
the challenge of this of this virus at
the moment we're in the contained phase
and that means that we still hope that
we may be able to contain this without
it becoming widespread but as soon as we
think that that isn't possible anymore
then of course we'll move on to the next
stages of the plan which are which are
very much in place should you cancel
your holiday to Italy you mentioned
there that it's the worst-affected in
Europe you should follow travel advice
and the travel advice has changed to the
affected parts of northern Italy to
advise against all but essential travel
there and if you go through an airport
you should be very careful and make sure
that you wash your hands airports our
airports are safe but they're places
where you should absolutely be following
the advice on washing your hands more
often and many people are worried of
course if about what would happen if
this does become a pandemic and how the
NHS would cave we've just heard from
John McDonnell who is claiming that ten
years of austerity has had its impact on
the health service and and whether or
not that means that there would be less
able to cope with a pandemic what's the
government line on this how many beds
are available yeah
well he's wrong the NHS is treating more
people than ever before but of course
that this would be a very big pressure
on the NHS depending on the scale of the
of the impact at the moment we've
already expanded the number of the the
high acute critical care beds that we
need and we've got the option to very
many expand that further should we need
it we've expanded it to 50 in the first
instance when there's relatively few
cases but that can go up we've got plans
to take that up to 500 and then 5,000 if
if that's necessary so we've got those
plans in place
the other thing that is in place which
of course is receiving a huge amount of
calls is NHS one-one-one and I just want
to say a great big thank you to
everybody who's working on NHS
one-one-one it only came in two or three
years ago it's been incredibly helpful
because it means that people can call
instead of going to their GP and that's
obviously safer for everybody
okay and now the Prime Minister will be
chairing a meeting of the emergency
committee Cobra tomorrow we know of
course that you've been chairing
meetings with officials over the last
week now of course everybody needs some
time off not everybody needs to be on TV
every time they're working but some will
be wondering if there's a bit of a
pattern forming Prime Minister very slow
to visit flood hit areas recently he
hasn't been working or he hasn't been in
number 10 this weekend why is it not
that the Prime Minister has been
chairing emergency committee meetings
already at a time when many people are
concerned about coronavirus and many
people will be looking to the Prime
Minister for leadership but the Prime
Minister's been all over this I have
daily calls with him often more than
once a day and I've been updating
cabinet weekly I've been chairing as you
say those those Cobra meetings cross
government not just officials but
ministers a case of ministers and
officials working incredibly well
together and the Prime Minister is fully
on top of all of this and and that's the
way it should be but he's part of the
team he leads the team and you know you
say that you question his work ethic I
tell you what last week he was did a
night shift at a hospital to find out
what it's really like on the frontline
at two o'clock in the morning I applaud
him for doing that I think it's I've
learned a lot from doing night shifts in
the NHS and I'm really glad that he has
he's done one too so the the PM's all
over this clearly I'm leading the
operational response and working
incredibly closely with him and every
other member of the government now
quinta asked why are we happy about
another big story this weekend so
Phillip Rahman the top civil servant in
the Home Office resigned says he's going
to be suing the government for
destructive dismissal after claiming the
Home Secretary mounted a vicious and
orchestrated campaign against him does
the government welcome people who speak
truth to power or are they just a
nuisance we work incredibly closely with
officials who who say exactly what the
the facts are as they see them and
advise and that's the that's the way it
should be and you know pretty is a is a
very determined person but she's also
very courteous and I think that the you
know if looking at coronavirus again the
way that officials and ministers have
work together has been absolutely
impeccable as well as of course the
medical and the medical experts and the
scientists and a great example of
everybody pulling together in the case
of of a big challenge and so I look I
don't know the details of this case and
clearly there's going to be a court case
I'm not going to go into the details but
what I'd say is that you know pretty we
all know that pretty is determined and
and that's right that's good in a
secretary of state that's what you want
to see and and she's also very courteous
in her dealings and I will very much
hope that we can we can get on and
deliver the government's agenda the
20,000 police that she's recruiting and
making sure that we crack down on crime
that's actually what people really care
about okay thank you so much for being
on the program this morning thank you